Doug good morning what did you think
last night I thought it was better than
advertised yeah I mean I actually Dan
was a Clemson a couple weeks ago and you
know science from from the area his
stepdad played I believe at Clemson and
everybody thought he was going there and
he turns around he goes to Duke and you
know how it goes when you don't get a
guy well you know he's a great dunker
but there's whole and it was necessarily
Clemson's basketball people but other
people you know had things well he
didn't play against great competition
and he was great he was great he was
efficient he played hard and then oh
yeah by the way they have RJ Barrett and
kam radish and they play great as well I
I think the Kentucky side might actually
be more interesting in terms of how bad
they were
and how ill-prepared they were and how
embarrassing their performance was and
maybe the lack of adjustments and maybe
that was purposeful but in terms of Zion
Williamson he was better than advertised
and that's really hard considering
considering the hype it's one thing
where you sometimes you'll find this and
you know this as well as anybody there's
a guy who's great in college but there's
a teammate who will be better in the
pros right do you see that with RJ
Barrett in Zion Williamson if you were
if you had the number one pick right now
I know it's early who would you take
yeah I probably take I probably take RJ
berry because enough of these guys that
have watched enough of these things all
tell me and I do things remember you
know this is you have to remember he's
going for the most part he's going not
just against college kids but you know
against Kentucky he's going against 18
year olds as well and he's going against
power forwards and centers so you have
to you know what is he in the NBA okay
he's gonna have to play the four he's
six foot five with long arms and 285
pounds which as I texted you only boban
weighs more in the NBA and there's just
this fear like dude you you know you
can't carry that much weight and play 82
games and though he's a kind of attica
unstoppable freight train going to the
hoop and you can see those tie
dunks with you know the empty Lane were
playing with the NBA you know you're
gonna have to do it against better
competition and so that'll be
interesting to see how it translates
right now I I don't think it's really
all that close because you know we're
looking at as we saw him in one game and
he's going to continue to be dominant to
college level but I would say RJ Barrett
because of his versatility is shot
making you know his game that the
position was NBA seems it seems like he
will translate a little bit better at
both ends
remember how you guard say like well
defense doesn't matter like ask some in
the NBA you can't guard you're just
gonna get lit up on a nightly basis but
I do think there's an X Factor design
Williamson there's and the fact that in
the white-hot spotlight of the first
game on national TV against Kentucky he
wasn't good he was great and I think he
played 23 minutes I think that's all he
played like it wasn't like he thought it
wasn't like there was a high volume it
was 13 shot it was it's a lot closer
than I would have thought if you ask me
before last night well I think also with
RJ Barrett we had dandaka John the
analyst for ESPN and he said there's
some James Harden in him and I went whoa
wait a minute
so I got harden at six four and I got RJ
Barrett at six nine or whatever is 610
and he said no his ability to kind of
find those spots to get in in between
the cracks there so I mean we're heaping
a lot of praise on these kids and we
went back and forth to when's the last
time America embraced Duke I don't
that's gonna be a hard one for people
it's good because that school never gets
a lot of attention about TV to find
somebody it's a good question I've been
racking up and listen to your show all
morning I'm kind of racking my brain I
can't remember there have been moments I
mean you know remember Kyrie only played
like eight games for Duke they're their
moments early on before he got heard
well it did feel like we liked that Duke
team where's Johnny yes when Johnny
Dawkins was there did we
well yeah that's before they won that
was when they were the underdog right
and and and they were great once they
stuff well when they had when they had
when they had Laettner it was hard it
was you know it was that was a team that
was hard to root for and then and then
they just kind of became a thing right
and then it wasn't helped by grace now
and tripping dudes that didn't help the
reputation and people just didn't like
JJ reddick and I don't really I don't
really get that one but I think once
they started once you start winning we
kind of turned on you and so I'm sure
that's coming for this Dib team at some
point future I mentioned that dick
Vitale's sort of inched up to the line
to say something critical of you know
Kansas situation and Arizona's situation
he didn't and maybe it wasn't the right
time or place to do it last night but it
feels like you know well I'm wondering
that but it's business as usual here in
college basketball and meanwhile you got
a coach with a player who's not suiting
up in you know for Kansas and his
assistant coach it is embroiled in this
controversy and guys are going to jail
for this and it's like nope nothing to
see here like wait what is anything
going to happen with this or am I just
kind of shouting you know into the end
of the wilderness
well like here's where Kansas has a
get-out-of-jail-free card
the court found that Kansas was the
victim right so like the NFA can go and
say well and and I this also yes let you
actually yesterday was the perfect time
predict by Taos a Hall of Famer see
whatever side he wants to take he can he
can take on national TV you know he's
got a lifetime contract there and he
chose to not do so and so that's that's
who he is that's his decision now
yesterday the it was announced that the
courts have given the NCAA now now you
have all or the fbi's now you have all
our documentation all this stuff and
that's really all the NCAA has ever
really wanted is hey we can't we don't
have subpoena power yeah we don't have
the power to have wiretap you do and so
they the FBI's done so much of the dirty
work for them now the the issue was
going after Kansas is the courts found
that Kansas was the victim so it's
really hard for the NCAA to turn around
and say well hey we think you guys broke
into a rules and guys were arranging
payments the player
I think some fireworks were going off
there and let's see if we can get Doug
back he can finish his thought there
here's something for you
Zion Williamson will appear in 31
nationally televised games this year the
number one pick in the draft DeAndre
eight and will appear in eight
nationally televised games the exposure
you get for your brand it's still great
for college basketball to have that
platform for these kids you know Diane
Williamson should be by all accounts
able to play in the NBA
RJ Barrett should be playing in the NBA
you know cam radish but Zions gonna be
in 31 nationally televised games this
year Doug is back with so you were
saying that Kansas is the victim well no
I didn't say that one accord stats what
was said yes that's what the court said
yeah so you know III think it's it's
really going to be hard for the NCAA to
make some case against Kansas and fight
and get bill self fired if the courts
are saying that they're the victim you
know I mean that's just a hard one yeah
but Bill Self is not a victim if it's
his staff whose staff member and you got
a kid who's sitting out right now
because they're sort of waiting to you
know to whatever kind of you know
they're the only reason why he's not
playing is they're worried if they play
him and then all of a sudden he's found
ineligible then they lose these games
here but do you think Bill Self should
have been should be coaching Kansas
right now yes I do think he should be
coaching Jim's okay he knew what was
going on with paying a paying a player I
think I I think he knew guys were
getting taken care of and he didn't want
to know I think that's generally the way
the way it works the difference is that
Pitino Pitino it feels like arranged for
everything to take place where itself
you know didn't want to know and just
you guys get it done however you guys do
whatever you
do we're gonna hurt the kid and and and
there's other you know other guys handle
that well we're for join what would be
my guess
yeah work for John Wooden you know like
I don't want to know but boy I keep
getting these great players showing up
at UCLA sure different era
but yes absolutely I mean look Lew
Alcindor was flying home to New York
every weekend during his freshman year
because he was homesick and John Wooden
didn't know that back in the day
look I you know I mean what does it say
about Mike she asked you though I do I
think Duke does it generally the right
way do but I also like okay so if other
people were willing to do whatever it
takes to get Diane Williamson and the
last second he changes his mind to go to
Duke was it just because it's Duke or
was it because you know it was because
Nike had a hand in it like that to
anyone anyone with a brain suspects that
so and I don't think I don't think Mike
sous-chefs key is on the phone with
these guys
arranging these these things to get the
deals done I also think a lot of this is
there's a lot of hearsay here right a
lot it's like it's like with your staff
if you ask them how many women they've
been with in their life right take it
and cut it in thirds or you know with
McLovin coveted ten and eight right
that's that's like college basketball or
high school basketball and what you're
getting oh I got paid I end up getting
an eighth of or didn't get any of what
you suspected you were going to get so
there's a lot of hearsay and talk and a
lawyer saying something but the fact
that Curtis Townsend assistant in Kansas
is on tape saying hey we got to do what
it takes to get this thing done that
doesn't indict Kansas but it does make
you think alright Kansas was might have
been willing to do some things or
arrange some things to be done but there
is no direct link to Bill Self so I
think he skates on it in addition to the
fact that the courts did find them a
victim yeah I know it goes on I just
think it's right in front of us now and
I don't think anybody cares I don't you
know what college basketball started I
don't think anybody cares about this
whatsoever it's like okay yeah you got a
kid and you got to pay him alright
but yeah
well I think I think the thing the thing
that's interesting is how little
actually goes to any of these kids
there's always everybody always has
their hands out and there's this layer
like kid just get most of them they just
want to go and play ball
that's it they just want to go and play
ball and they just want to be on TV and
they want to wear the good gear and they
want to play for a good coach and they
want to play the Nash for a national
championship and they want to go to the
NBA and and this is a we're talking a 1%
you know a top 5% or 1% of the actual
kids that play in college it's a very
small percentage that have their hands
out and and usually the kids don't have
their hands out it's the parents or
their handler thank you Doug great to
talk to you again we appreciate your
time as always
all right that's a Doug Gottlieb for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]